much of southeastern louisiana was put
under mandatory evacuation orders before
ida hit as a category 4 hurricane
yesterday tens of thousands of people
fled to safety
including
folks that are where our maria
villarreal is in huma louisiana maria
hey good morning vlad so take a look
this is what is happening in downtown
houma right now louisiana this is a
small community about 33 000 people and
this is pretty much the way all of the
buildings look here in the heart of this
city downtown off of main street
buildings are almost all collapsed here
in this area we've seen power lines
everywhere debris so as the sun rises
here in houma really what we're going to
be taking a hard look at is the damage
and some of the damage that people need
to assess and are going to carefully
look at is what happened to the local
hospitals so here's what we know
hospitals are starting to see the damage
already they were assessing overnight
the state's largest hospital system
oxnard says that they are reporting roof
damage and water leaks at several of its
facilities some locations in new orleans
and the bayou region are already on
backup generators we know when we heard
that was happening here in houma as well
take a look this is the view from the
10th floor of one of the facilities in
jefferson watch as debris from the roof
flies off it looks like it's going to
hit someone now on sunday the ceo of
this health system said that some of its
smaller rural hospitals had already
started to proactively evacuate patients
before ida made landfall we saw those
ambulances leaving houma just a few days
ago trying to make sure that the most
critical got out of this area patients
at two other hospitals one in raceland
with 21 patients and another here in
houma that has 45 patients will soon be
evacuating two other facilities as soon
as this morning the hospital system says
that any facilities in this area could
be affected by ida for about 10 days
actually what they are saying right now
is as they are affected we do understand
that they have supplies that will keep
them up and running for at least 10 days
on top of the generators that they
already have we have spoken to a number
of evacuees some that are staying in our
hotel
we do not have power did not have power
went out late late yesterday and so
really what a lot of these evacuees are
saying is we're going to try and somehow
make it home to check on our loved ones
to check on our homes to see what the
damage is but we don't even know if
we're going to get here so really as the
sun rises we're going to see a lot of
people come out and really figure out
what has happened to their communities
vlad
medea thank you very much i know you'll
be following those individuals as they
make their way home
thank you so much